la société française et les sociétés
européennes on traverse une grande crise
des politiques publiques nous avons raté
notre politique d'intégration
nous avons raté notre politique
d'urbanisation nous n'avons pas un
système de formation permanente
suffisamment établis nous n'avons pas un
système d'instruction civique respectez
donc c'est un affaissement globale de la
société de la communauté républicaine
nous n'avons pas été capables de faire
face aux défis qui étaient les nôtres
autrement que par une solidarité
financière alors là très général très
généreuse très nécessaire comme on l'a
vu pendant la pandémie est pas
suffisante car donner de l'argent à tout
le monde c'était sans doute nécessaire
mais ça ne remplace pas le lien social
entre entre les fonds c'est donc je
crois que nous devons aujourd'hui
réinventer un bien commun comme disait
la saint thomas d'aquin un intérêt
général comme une volonté générale comme
disait rousseau je pense que ça passe
par la reconstitution
de collectivités territoriales
décentralisées puissante la
reconstitution d'établissements
scolaires doté d'une certaine
personnalité autonome scolaire ou
universitaire que ça passe par
effectivement un développement comme le
disait tocqueville de mouvements
associatifs tourné vers l'action
humanitaire par exemple ça passe par des
entreprises dans lequel il ya un vrai
dialogue social
et ça passe aussi par le rétablissement
d'une démocratie plus équilibré dans
lequel le parlement qui est quand même
le parent pauvre de la démocratie soit
respectée et une répartition des
compétences entre l'état central les
collectivités territoriales et puis
chacun d'entre nous les familles etc qui
fasse que chacun sente où est la
responsabilité
et oui il faut agir alors
qu'actuellement on a l'impression que le
pouvoir c'est une espèce de de grands
nuages un peu sombre qui s'abat sur nous
nous enveloppe de froid et de pluie ou
de chaleur sans qu'on sache tout à fait
pourquoi